[Music]
hello everyone
welcome to the google cloud video
learning series
my name is lou deletori i'm a customer
engineer at google cloud
and today i'll show you how to export
logs from google cloud logging
to bigquery here i am in the google
cloud console
you can quickly find the bigquery
service by typing bigquery
in the search products and resources
field
and then selecting bigquery
in the navigation pane in the resources
section
select your project
on the right side of the window in the
details panel click
create data set
in the create data set window under data
set id enter a unique
name
in data location accept the default
which is us
in default table expiration select
number of days after table creation and
i'll enter
7. under encryption
accept the default google managed key
and select
create data set
next we'll want to turn on audit logging
for all services
by default data access audit logs are
disabled
except for bigquery in order to enable
all audit logs
we'll need to first download the current
im policy as a file
then add the audit log policy yaml
object to the current policy file
then update our project with the updated
policy i'll demonstrate how to configure
your project's data access audit logs
using the gcloud command and google
cloud console
first open the cloud shell by clicking
on activate cloud shell
then read the project's im policy and
store it in a file by running this
command
click on authorize cloud shell if
prompted
then edit the policy file stored in temp
policy.yaml using vi and
add the data access audit logs
configuration
be sure to preserve the bindings and
e-tag sections without changes
otherwise you might cause your project
to become unstable
save and exit the file then write the
new impolicy to the project by running
this command
next we'll need to refine the logging
filters to export
audit logs including admin activity and
data access audit logs
you could also enable logs for specific
resource types if you like
we'll use the gcloud logging syncs
create command to create a sync
called gcp underscore logging underscore
sync
underscore bq for the project
by running this command
in the service account entry returned
from the api call
the identity is included in the response
this identity represents a google cloud
service account that has been created
for the export
until you grant this identity write
access to the destination
log entry exports from the sync will
fail so let's go ahead
and copy the identity
to add the permissions to the service
account select the data set
in my case gcp underscored logging
underscore export
and select share data set
in the add members field paste the
service account that we just copied
then select a role
select bigquery and bigquery data editor
to provide the permissions necessary
click add and click
done
after you create the logging export by
using this filter log files begin to
populate the bigquery data set in a
configured project
you can now run a broad range of queries
against the audit logs to better
understand
who's accessing data on google cloud or
you can use a tool like google data
studio to help you visualize the data
well that concludes the demo please stay
tuned for future videos on how to use
other components of the google cloud
operation suite
as well as other services have a great
[Music]
day